- And number two, you have to,
outside of your job, build your skills
in this world.
Otherwise, you'll be vulnerable.
Period.
(whooshing)
Good morning.
Really nice to meet you guys.
I'd love to do as much Q&A as possible.
I'll pick it up from that point.
In 2009, on the back of
a lot of success early in my life,
especially by investing in Facebook
and Twitter, it became
very obvious to me that
the world was about
to go through a substantial change
and that this internet thing was
far bigger than what I
even thought as a kid
and that we were just in the beginning.
Not the end.
And I think sometimes,
especially for you guys,
like, you know how timing is right,
you think it's over.
It's like a band you like.
You think it's over but they didn't
even start getting big,
even though you've been on for
a year and a half, that's kind of
how I felt about the internet as a whole.
My father-in-law was Jim
Kilts' right hand marketing guy
at Nabisco, Kraft and Gillette.
And so at family functions, barbecues
and random times, I would hear them talk
about big brands and they were winning.
They were like considered like winning
and they were doing all the right things.
Every company had turned around.
And then something very
interesting had happened.
I went on vacation with my wife
and I don't really read a lot books ever.
Like I've read nine in my life,
but one of them was about
the private equity firm 3G,
which went on to buy Budweiser and Kraft
and Hines and I was reading it
and just kind of this
series of life is funny.
Sometimes it's about
getting the pieces together
at the right moment
and having the time to think
and really the only time I think
is on this vacation
and so I'm kind of walking the beach
and kind of out like a
central casting movie, I
was like, fuck, it just all clicked,
which is, huh, if 3G's gonna win,
and I think they are,
and this was in 2009,
for buying Burger King, firing everybody.
Maximizing profit.
Wall Street's gonna like that.
That made sense to me.
If Facebook and Twitter and YouTube
are gonna win, television's
gonna get disrupted
even more so.
And I thought it was already dead
by commercial's standards.
As we're here this week,
it's still very much on an
emotional pedestal and so,
(cheering)
I basically starting putting things
together in my mind and saying, wow.
Private equity, these brands and then I
really thought Amazon
was a very big company
at the time and it's now been proven
to be that,
and I was like, I think retail
is in trouble.
My dad, this business
that we're referring to,
my dad had a liquor store in New Jersey.
I launched one of the first
3E commerce wine businesses
in American and just everything
just kind of came together.
My brother was graduating college.
We wanted to start a business together
and then ESPN a week later asked me
to come in an consult and they said we'll
give you five thousand dollars for an hour
and I was like, fuck.
So, it was all kind of coming together
and I was like, you know, there's,
it might be time for me
to leave Silicon Valley.
I'd done the entrepreneur, entrepreneur,
like real entrepreneur shit.
Not this new tech version, like being
in a liquor store 15 hours a day
for 10 years.
I need to figure out this
corporate American thing
because it's big and it's wrong.
And knowing that I was a D
and F student, I couldn't
go MBA it out
or hire a couple of people.
I just don't learn that way.
I was like, let me go eat shit
for a decade.
I'm gonna build an agency.
I didn't even know what that meant.
I called my company VaynerMedia.
We only did creative for
the first four years.
Like, I didn't know that media
and creative was separate.
When I tell you I knew nothing,
like I'd never heard
of WPP or David Ogleby
or any, I was 34 years old, starting
an agency and never heard anything
that you'll hear the whole day.
I didn't know what Canne was.
I didn't know what ad age was.
I didn't know Wieden and Kennedy was.
I knew nothing.
Here's what I knew.
I knew that the end consumer
wasn't being communicated
to properly and that
within the first six months
and 10 or 15 meetings and
a little bit of reading,
I knew the whole thing was trading
on the wrong things.
Here's the amazing
advantages when you don't
come from the world.
A couple things.
When you walk into the world
and you find out the Nielsen ratings
are super important to
justify things, you what
a new person does, like me,
who's an operator.
You try to figure out how Nielsen ratings
are being measured.
What you realize very
quickly, is like, holy shit,
this is mathematically correct
but not practically correct.
You can't have two thousand boxes
and people calling people and asking them
if they watched Charlie Rose last night
to figure out if,
it was absurd.
And the absurdity continued every day.
And so, a couple things
that I'd like to establish.
Number one, I think creative is
the variable of success for brands.
So, I'm not a mathematician or a quant guy
or you know, to me, Just Do It.
Where's The Beef, Priceless.
It is the holy grail.
When you produce something that gets
everybody to know, that's how
the human brain makes decisions.
It's not 'cuz we cookie them
and follow them around and buy.
My problem, though, is I'm
also unbelievably practical.
My whole life has been, my work
has to put food on the table.
Not win awards.
Not get headlines.
Not get me a promotion.
So, I've always cared if it works.
There isn't a commercial today
that works because nobody's
watching television commercials.
That's just the truth.
And it's a truth me and
the creative community
have to start accepting because otherwise,
we're gonna have this rub
and otherwise, we're gonna continue
to see what we're seeing,
which is the biggest brands in the world
over the last seven years
have declined massively.
They're losing market share every day.
And we have to start having
the proper conversation.
And so to me, we're in this
amazing perfect time now
where it's never been
better to be a creative.
You have unlimited flexibility.
It's like being in
production in Hollywood.
It's great now.
Everyone's winning because there's Hulu
and Amazon Prime and Netflix and HBO and,
there's so many places to sell your work.
Hollywood's figured it out.
They were shitting on
Netflix five years ago.
Now they're like kissing its face
because it opened up everything.
I literally, I'd love for the front row
to see this.
I have huge goosebumps right now
because as I'm saying
it, I'm so passionate
because I love this space.
Because you know, the thing that sucks
about being in something in
10 years, you meet people
and you like them and just
like the thing, right?
I love this industry.
I hate that it hasn't figured out
that the second they put the romance
of television away, we will all flourish.
I don't know what else to say.
There is no Just Do It commercial
over the last 10 years.
There isn't a commercial
that has driven business
like they used to in the
'70s and '80s and '90s,
'cuz people don't watch them.
And now on the flip side, Superbowl
is the best piece of
advertising opportunity
in the world.
To me, the Superbowl commercial is
the number one place I would spend money
on a TV spot.
But it's a singular unit.
Literally, the Oscars and the Tony's
and the NFC championship game
and the World Cup, all
that stuff, garbage.
People don't watch it.
It's black and white.
And so, Hollywood, to their credit,
quickly got off their bullshit
and said fuck it, because
the economics were there.
When Netflix started writing big checks,
it was fine, right?
The reason we haven't, is that's
not what happened.
The reason it hasn't happened in our world
is 'cuz the holding companies
aren't incentivized to change.
There's nothing else to say.
That's just real life business.
There's more margin in
selling programmatic digital
and selling television
than any other category.
Thus, that is the continued propaganda
of our industry to the
demise of creative work.
The fact that you can
make a 17 minute film
on Facebook that if it was fucking awesome
and you play on the media properly would
really sell and make
people excited is amazing.
You know, the work that I'm most proud of
at VaynerMedia are all long form videos.
Facebook says don't do
it 'cuz it doesn't work
for their three second views.
You know, the brands don't us to do it.
Nobody want's us to do it,
but every time we do it, miraculously,
the product sells at supermarkets
and Walmarts and things of that nature.
And that's even with the
risk of the creative missing.
And it still works because
it's so being consumed
in those environment.
Yet unfortunately, and
I have a lot of empathy
for this room, you don't grow up dreaming
about writing one singular
tweet like for Wendy's
or Moon Pie that can change it's business.
It's just not what you're here for.
We're not here in this
sunny fuckin' place, right,
for a, you know, the pedestal isn't about
a one minute 19 second video that's
a preroll on YouTube
before something else.
It's just not what's on a pedestal
and it's wrong.
And it's wrong.
And I believe that and
so, I'm very passionate
to continue to communicate that
and what really bugs me the most
is that when you think about audio,
the rise of audio, sonic advertising,
the fact that every brand should have
a jingle and a three second sound
that we can associate with.
The fact that you can
make five minute videos.
The fact that you can make 11 videos
for a brand instead of one,
is in theory, amazing for creative.
Like, wouldn't you want to make 11 videos
instead of one?
Look at this room.
Nobody here looks the same.
Shouldn't, if I'm Dove, make one
for African American females,
make one for white guys with blonde hair,
make one for psycho-graphic, demographic,
financial, interests, shouldn't I?
The answer's yes.
But the system forces us to do
a subjective vanilla tag line
that should work for everybody
and then make one 30 fucking second video
that should work for
everyone, AKA white people
and the shit doesn't hit.
And everybody who's smart knows it.
Or has looked up.
The biggest vulnerability,
the reason, if I'm talking right now,
everybody's like huh,
is you just haven't looked up.
'Cuz you're in your shit
and you should be, right?
You're trying to win, trying to establish.
I get it.
You just haven't looked up.
And the thing that,
the reason I continue
to only do this event
at this place is because I want you to win
and you're not gonna play in the,
my friends, your career will not play out
based on the tone of this festival.
You will not live during
the television commercial
on a pedestal era.
That is not your career.
And the quicker you figure
that out, the better.
You know and so, you know,
and I think that this group
is the most vulnerable because you're even
in this room.
If you're a young protege
of this system, you're
the most vulnerable because you're
being seduced by it.
Make sense?
This is an honor to be here, right?
So now you're in the fucking vortex.
Now you want your face on a poster
out there for a 30 second spot
for Coca-Cola and I think that's
a big fuckin' mistake.
And I know I'm right
and deep down, I know you know I'm right
and I know you know it.
And so now the question becomes
what do you do about it.
And so for me,
it's just a very common
sense conversation.
A couple things I would
highly recommend you do
so it's actionable.
Please do not disrespect social networks.
Every one of them download
and create for it.
On the side, start a side hustle.
Sell peanut butter direct on Amazon
and do all the creative on internet.
Please learn the skills
because you do not, you
are the most vulnerable
creative generation
because when this actually fully hits tilt
in the next five to seven years, you're
gonna be deep in your career and you're
gonna be judged for being
part of this machine
and you're not gonna get the best jobs
because you're gonna be dissed for being
a person of the print, of the outdoor,
of the television, of the banner.
You will.
So you have to be very thoughtful.
And by the way, I'm a historian.
If you don't believe me,
go read what happened to everybody
who got killed during the transition
of radio to television.
Go read of all the executives,
all the brands, all the creatives
that lost in the late '40s through
the early '60s when we had the rub
between radio becoming television
as the main platform.
The internet is the main platform.
Guys, I used to think that you would
all, this town would wake up
and stop doing commercials.
I didn't realize that OTT was gonna come
and there'd be no commercials.
ABC, NBC, CBS, they're all dead.
They're gone.
Just a matter of time now.
So, they don't even exist.
Not how OTTs are gonna play.
So, be it a much more fun
creative world, I think.
You're gonna have to figure out
how to integrate brands into creative.
Or start original shows.
Like it's all started, soap operas, right?
Like who knows where this takes us,
but please don't,
when people become romantic of the past,
we go into a bad place.
We accept that socially.
We haven't accepted it in
the advertising industry.
We put something on a pedestal that
is completely irrelevant
to the end consumer.
I don't know what else to say.
How's the television commercial
penetrating your life?
It's inconceivable.
And you're in the industry.
You don't see them and
you're in the industry.
So, how does a normal person see it?
So, I'm very passionate about this
and I'm really passionate
for you guys, especially.
And you have to,
it doesn't mean that the copy writing
has never been more important.
You have 5000 places to put it in.
I write different copy on Instagram
than I do on Facebook
than I do on Twitter.
It's the same fucking audience,
but the platform's different, so I know
their psychology's different.
So, I copy write different.
Like, the first three seconds
of every video, I think about differently.
What's the platform?
What's the context?
Twitter only lets me go for 240 or 280.
Instagram's a minute.
Instagram's about to be longer.
I'm already like spending enormous amount
of time, like what does
long form Instagram mean?
'Cuz that's where the attention is.
There is no fashion or cool brand
that hasn't been built on Instagram
in the last 36 months.
You think Champion became Champion
on the back of television commercials?
You think Stan Smith's did that on TV?
You think LaCroix did that on TV?
Please pay attention.
Where's Off White's commercial?
What do you think's happening?
So, I get it, 'cuz you're in it.
And you guys are really in it.
Everybody in the industry's in it.
You're really in 'cuz you're
sitting here right now.
And so it gets even more dangerous
and it's something you
have to think about.
Because it's not gonna play out.
We're not going backwards.
Creative is still the most important,
but creative gets redefined
all the time, right?
I mean, I built my dad's
store on newspaper copy.
Let's call it what it is.
It's email, it was
Google Adwords for sure,
but I fucking dominated newspapers.
I would sit, fuckin'
late a shit, designing
that full page ad in the New York Times
and it fuckin' worked every time
'cuz I knew the end consumer better
than anybody in the liquor business
and I knew and I got really really good
at understanding how to make a piece
of newspaper advertising to stop you
as you were going through the food section
on Wednesday in the New York Times.
It was fuckin' fun.
It was creative.
It was interesting.
And then email and open rates.
But making one fucking video
and then chopping it up for
preroll programmatic shit,
what are we doing?
That's where I'm at.
Questions.
Yes, sir.
What's your name?
- Harvey.
- Thanks for coming out.
- Yeah, man.
- [Harvey] I make
(mumbles)
digital videos for a living.
- Love it.
- [Harvey] All of our clients,
because they're so being sold
by these holding companies
and bigger agencies,
still want a 30 second--
- Yup.
- With a six second cut down.
What are you telling people
to get them away from that
and saying, look, just
learn from stuff that works.
People wanna see it when they're
engaged with the products.
- What we're telling them is it's wrong
and this is what they
should do on Facebook.
The problem is, 89% of the time, we can't
get them there.
This was our big year.
We finally started, you know, we
got a pinnacle AOR thing.
We became Budweiser's AOR thing.
We've got some momentum in
(mumbles)
I think 2019 is gonna be the year Vayner
can help the industry because I think we
in the position to do enough work
and then there's also, I'm looking
at Jason Hammonds, who just went from
the VaynerMedia production side
to I bought PureWow,
women's publishing company
and then last week, I launched ONE37pm
which is a men's publishing
and we're doing the brand and content work
but I think there's a
2.0 version of that vice,
refinery, you know, bleach report work
and we're gonna be doing that
and it's a little bit more agency centric,
even though those companies
were good agencies.
This is like fucking,
we're making agency work,
and we've already seen
something with Proctor.
Very substantial on the PureWow side.
I think this is gonna be,
and honestly, this where
I think my responsibility,
oh so, my concept is,
I'm gonna buy brands.
Why did I start the agency?
'Cuz I'm gonna buy K-Swiss or Mountain Dew
or Mug Root Beer or Head and Shoulders.
I'm gonna buy brands.
The brands are gonna die.
When the economy collapses,
they're gonna sell them for nothing
'cuz they're gonna have to survive.
I'm gonna buy them and
I'm gonna build Proctor
and Gamble from the ground up.
That's my 30 year mission.
That's why I got in.
But, while they're paying me, I feel
an enormous responsibility.
I live this bizarro world.
I'm desperately trying to get them
to do something, yet as they continue
to do the stuff I just talked about,
it's in my benefit long term
because it's why they're gonna die
and why I can buy them for cheap.
And I do feel a huge responsibility
while we're an agency getting paid.
I have to give the best advice first.
Strategy first.
And we do,
much to what I thought
would happen is happening.
They're not moving,
but Budweiser's credit, we did
a bunch of work last year.
It all worked.
The Jeter stuff.
The Harry Caray stuff.
All that stuff worked
and an anomaly no longer does
the above the line work.
We do, what is in essence, is them,
the new Budweiser above the line work,
which is, it starts at Facebook
and whatever works goes above the line
and it's really working in sales.
'Cuz people see the Facebook videos.
I don't know what else to tell you.
Yes.
- [Woman] I feel like it's really hard
to get them to trust you on that topic
and we discussed that one of
our big line beauty clients
and I think they are the worst, so,
and it's a nightmare because they
don't really trust you at all.
When you tell them, okay, this is
what we should do and we have to,
a lot of diverse content excess
that speak to different audiences
and they are like,
but they don't have the numbers yet.
(mumbles)
Data impacted number so we find it
very very hard to let them to trust us
and then for them, it's like
there's the VP of marketing.
If he doesn't do it right this year,
he's gonna be fired.
There's gonna be another
douchebag next year.
- Yup.
- I find it
very hard to build that relationship.
- I agree.
- Be like, guys, I trust you
and we do it that way.
- I agree.
- Any ideas on how we can--
- No.
And I mean it.
What I think you need to do
is two things.
One, if I'm you and this
is now for you personally,
for your life.
For you and your kids.
Not like you need to be on the record
so that everybody in
this environment knows
what your opinions are.
The biggest fear I have for you
is you yes people to
death because you know
what's accepted and then six years later,
people judge you and be like, whoa, I
was in four meeting with you.
You love TV, fuck you.
Got it?
So, that's dangerous.
You need to find a way
of not getting fired
but still saying your piece
so that it's on the record
and number two, you have to, outside
of your job, build your
skills in this world.
Otherwise you will be vulnerable.
Period and that's it.
You're exactly right.
I mean, when I talk to Beauty Brands
and we work between my VaynerX world,
between VaynerMedia and the Purell side,
we work with everybody.
Unilever, Proctor.
You know, J and J, L'Oréal, Revlon.
Duh duh duh duh duh.
I have the same meeting with all of them
in the last hundred days.
It was like, do you know how
much Kylie Jenner's brand
has done direct to consumer
in the last 12 months?
Does anybody here know how much revenue
it's done in the first 12 months?
(audience replies)
Revenue.
(audience member replies)
That's exactly right.
Four hundred eighty
million dollars in sales.
From zero.
Because, and by the way,
it is not because she has so many Snapchat
and Instagram followers and her posts.
It's 'cuz they're marketing on social.
And it's a brand and there is the,
of course, but these are real numbers now.
You know how many L'Oréal and Revlon
and you know, Estee Lauder brands even
do that much?
Not most.
So, you know, I talk,
the reason I've been able to break through
a little bit, Vayner,
is I go to the highest levels
and I only talk business.
Only business.
They're all CFO driven.
It has nothing to do with the CMO.
It has nothing to do with the CEO.
Just fucking math.
And I just talk business
and the real business is the retailers
are taking all their
money 'cuz they're pouring
all their money into trade.
They're barely marketing anymore
and when they market, it's not working.
And listen, the reason, I don't know
where you work what
the exact relationship,
but like, I sit in these
meetings, I've not sat
with a traditional creative shop
that's playing around here and watched
them deviate from
anything 30 seconds spots
and the media company,
forget about it.
They're not gonna let you
have any breathing room
'cuz all their money's
on programmatic and television.
They lose money on Facebook.
They lose money doing
proper prerolll Google.
They lose money on Influencer.
That's going to PR.
They're not gonna do that.
Got it?
- To that point,
one of the reason the agencies
aren't selling Facebook
is because they're the enemy.
- A hundred thousand percent.
- They take their lunch.
So, television's safe.
- And profitable, and profitable.
You know how fun it is to be a big hold,
it's the only advantage
a holding company has.
VaynerMedia has won the
Digital Media Business
from Chase, from Mondelēz, from tons
of companies because that's done on merit.
That's a skill.
You have to plan it.
You have just creative,
like, it's a skill.
A holding company, like
a WPP and an Omniom,
they just use their buying power
to get a better rate with CBS and ABC.
I can't do that.
So, that's to their advantage.
Then they upfront commit
and they force their clients
to spend on those platforms regardless
of it matters to them or not.
- [Man] And Facebook, they've
got their own creative to bargain.
They're very creative people.
- Yeah and to your, yeah,
but I'll tell you this,
the Facebook creative department, I love
a lot of those characters, but they're not
doing Facebook any favors.
They're pushing things for Facebook.
They're no different.
For example, they tell everybody in here
to make sure the logo's shown
in the first three seconds
'cuz they're reporting
a Brainly study is predicated on that.
It's the worst thing you could do.
Show a person a brand in
the first three seconds
of a video, they're out.
Make a video people actually
wanna watch, they're in.
We made a Dunkin' Donuts video
that we got shit on by Facebook,
by the client, by the
incumbents, by everybody,
and it fuckin' dominated 'cuz it was
a music video and it was fuckin' funny
and people liked it.
And then when we retargeted the people
that watch two minutes
and 12 seconds of it
with a coupon, they fuckin' converted
because they fuckin' were happy with us
'cuz we did branding.
Go figure.
Yes, sir.
What's your name?
- Stephano.
- [Stephano] To these questions.
I come from FM City Company
and sometimes when we
evaluate marketing needs
there's a media complication structure.
They come with some number, such shows,
certain title, more
traditional media pays off
a bit better when compared to like,
on the basis of sales and consumer basing.
- It's because they
model the MMM internally
to make that happen.
- [Stephano] My question is,
all of these numbers, are they due
to the industry propaganda or is it just--
- A hundred, a hundred percent.
- [Stephano] Or is it
just a turning moment
where they are actually still a bit better
but it will turn in one or two years.
- A hundred percent,
the internal MMMs,
so again, one of the great things
that happened to me, I'm a businessman
that came into the industry and
every time somebody would say something,
it, you know, I'll be honest with you.
I didn't come in with an
opinion about television.
I thought it was gonna be fun
to make television commercials
and see them and be like,
oh shit, I made that up.
(laughing)
Like, I get it.
When I came in, I was like, you're,
but of course, your internal MMM
is measuring TV better.
You made it that way.
Like you made this scale,
it's like saying a scale
measures your weight.
No shit.
It didn't, like hey, calories don't matter
'cuz the scale measures your weight.
Really?
Got it?
That's what it is, my friends.
Like, if you're not math nerded out
how they do it.
For example, Stephano, you know
what else happens?
There's a human element to these MMMs.
So, for example, when people
tell you internal numbers
show a better row-az
on TV or these things,
do you know that a human being's allowed
to come in 99% of the time and say,
well, it was too nice outside this weekend
and so we should adjust it
by a couple percentage points
'cuz it wasn't fair on TV because
it was sunny and the people probably went
to the beach and so, like, you know,
for creatives or like, if you
don't look, you don't know.
If you're not educated, like,
so, yes, it is propaganda.
- [Stephano] Yeah, thank you.
(laughs)
- Like everything in this world
is built to protect the
most profitable things
for the holding company.
The only way you could get somebody
to do something is make
them aware of something.
So, whether you're telling people
to go under your shelter 'cuz
a tornado is coming or you want
them to buy a bandana or a root beer,
it's the same game.
The only game that matters is attention.
It's the only currency that matters.
Because without it, you
can't say your thing.
You're at the mercy,
this is what makes me heartbroken
for all the beautiful
and wonderful creatives
in this room and in this place.
Nobody's seen your shit.
So, to me it's underpriced
and overpriced attention.
Everything's available.
If you have unlimited
money, do everything.
Because if a billboard's worth 800 dollars
but you paid ten thousand for it,
well, you're still gonna get
some people to see it.
But that's not the question at hand.
The question at hand is when you have
a certain amount of budget,
what's underpriced and what's overpriced,
to allow you to hit the maximum reach.
The problem is the industry
is based on potential reach,
not actual reach.
I understand how many GRPs
and how many homes
could be watching Empire
or this play off game.
I'm asking you how many people
actually consumed the commercial.
I know how many times a video shows
up in your stream.
I'm asking you how many times
has somebody watched it.
Here's what I know.
We penalize things like Facebook
and Google where we
can actually measure it
and we're rewarding
platforms that we can't.
We've accepted reports
from a hundred years ago
that are big, but they're not real.
How are you measuring a radio spot?
Do you know how print is measured?
It's measured on circulation
and a multiple of.
When you make a print ad for Vogue, you
are paying for eight times the amount
of Vogues that are printed that
that page 98 is gonna be seen
by eighth times the amount of magazines,
because the theory was magazines travel
and that when you left Vogue on the bus,
the next person picked it up
and also saw page 99.
Eight of them.
Meanwhile, I real life, four
of the billion people that possibly read
that thing ever get to page 99
and actually look at that picture
and really consume it.
Or you can go on Instagram
where every fuckin' person in the world
is living right now and looking
at fucking people wearing clothes.
It's so fucked that they now charge
more for just internet because they need
the fake subscription numbers on cable
to justify the commercial expense,
so they can go in a conference and
be like, there's still 39 million people
with fuck that haven't cut their cord.
No shit, but none of them are watching
a fucking commercial.
And that's what we're talking about.
Listen carefully.
Two years ago, I was listening
very carefully to a lot of the talks.
Television isn't dead.
You know, duh duh.
Like Breaking Bad, this and that.
They talk about shows.
They don't talk about commercials.
And now it's over.
OTT is gonna win, we all know it.
I mean, think about your own,
but don't think about your consumptions.
Go and talk to 80 year olds.
They're on Netflix and Prime, you know.
What are people doing?
- Hi.
- [Raquel] I'm Raquel and I was wondering,
it's actually quite a technical question
- Okay.
- about social media.
So, you know social media and publishing
on it, it's always about the timing.
- Sure.
- So, what is
the best way to organically,
if it's possible, measure the peak
of your following on social media
so you can publish accurately during
the time that they're holding--
- That's a great question.
I think the best way to do it
is produce an ungodly amount of content
and measure it over a period of time.
So, Facebook and Instagram aren't
gonna tell you that.
There was a lot of start
ups seven, eight years ago
that were trying to figure out the time
to post perfectly.
Facebook and Instagram and others
have shut down their APIs to really
give you that data.
If you're a smart publisher,
a brand,
so, it's interesting.
We're spending a lot time getting back
to Twitter and volume content.
I think that you should be posting
all the time and getting an understanding
of your audience and that
if you made aggressive calendar 90
to 100 days and then analyze the data, you
will see patterns.
I don't agree with that.
I think you should be publishing,
for example, let's use Instagram
since it's such a player
right now, I think.
One man's point of view.
The ideal amount of times
that a brand should post on Instagram
on main feed, not stories, is six.
- [Raquel] Six in a day?
- In a day.
So, let's talk about it.
Let's talk about it.
Number one, first of all,
that's just organic.
That's not even what I think you
should be doing on paid ads,
which is spending all your money on it.
- Yeah.
- Like all of it.
Like, you would be
stunned how much I think,
I think 80% of brands in America
should spend more than 60% of their
overall budget on Facebook and Instagram.
60 and I'm talking about regardless
of the brand, 'cuz Facebook's so deep now.
First of all, you have
to understand something.
For example, my Instagram.
I have 3.4 million followers
on Instagram, okay?
When I post,
on my views on a video,
two hundred thousand
to five hundred thousand, right,
and that's with sharing
and people tagging.
You're not reaching most of your audience
to begin with, so if you're a brand
that posting six time a day,
on your most, what you have to understand,
what people don't understand
about the algorithm.
The algorithm that Instagram
and Facebook implement
is the most perfect and I
mean perfect product I've
ever seen in marketing.
You have to understand why.
Their interests align with you.
The only thing Facebook
and Instagram make money on
is you staying on the platform.
So, all of their,
unlike television, unlike radio,
unlike print, unlike websites
that put banners everywhere,
the entire machine is built
on you staying.
So, if you love a brand like Heineken,
you'll probably see three of those
because you've shown through your actions
that you like it.
If you follow Adidas
and the first seven post
don't tickle your fancy
and you don't engage, you'll probably
only see one every 12 over two days
of the organic posting.
So, you can't overwhelm on Facebook
and Instagram because Facebook
and Instagram is protecting you.
Unlike email.
Unlike Twitter.
Unlike other platforms.
Facebook and Instagram is
not showing your creative
to all your people organically.
- [Raquel] Well,
(mumbles)
they go to your feed, like the timeline?
- No.
(audience member replies)
- [Raquel] They filter them now?
- Yes.
News feeds been around for a long time.
- [Raquel] Even if
you're following someone?
- That's correct.
- Yeah.
(audience member replies)
- Now you can set,
yup, I'll be right with you.
You can set, like,
if it's your best friend or
if you're a huge fan of somebody,
you can set notifications and they
can force that and you'll see every one,
but it is now filtered
and has been for a long time.
And it's why you can do so much more.
Now, the bigger conversation
for advertisers,
this is not now your mom and pop store
or you as a person, is you should
be running ads.
The ads are so unpriced right now
that you should be running ads.
So, if you're Adidas, you should
be running ads against Nike fans
or against people that
are, buy athletic shoes
or just 18 to 25 that are into hip hop.
A million things you
should be buying ads on.
For me building anything,
whether it's a personal brand
or a brand or a PSA or anything
of that nature, it's just
about value exchange.
You know, like why do I have
a lot of followers on Instagram?
Because I motivate people
and I give them information
that helps them with their
personal brand and business.
That's a value exchange.
It's not because I'm super hot.
Other people,
other people have three million followers
'cuz they're super attractive
and we like attractive people.
Other people are great at sports.
We love to see the highlight.
Other people are funny.
It's value exchange.
I want something.
You're giving me something.
It's human nature.
You need to figure out
the single best thing
that you bring value in, right?
And the problem is, most people don't like
to give their best work away for free.
That's what I figured out.
I give away all my advice for free.
My best advice.
The stuff I could sell
for a thousand dollars.
Ebooks and 25 thousand
dollar master minds.
I give it all away for free
because that is the ultimate leverage
because I'm bringing the most value
and I want the attention
'cuz I think attention
is the ultimate asset.
Got it?
And some incredible relationship
when you hit that crescendo.
I'm giving away all my best shit.
You're giving me attention
which gives me leverage, right?
Gives me permission to ask
when I have a sneaker out
or a book or something, right?
I'll convert higher if I gave you
a ton of it.
People literally buy shit from me
'cuz they feel guilty.
Like people send me emails all the time.
Like, I bought wine from
your dad's liquor store
'cuz fuck, you know, you changed my career
and I haven't given you a dollar
so I fuckin' bought some rose
for my grandma.
If you really,
and the problem is most people don't know
how to provide value.
Or let's be honest.
Let's really get there.
Sometimes you just don't have
a lot to, you know, I don't know.
It's a, what's amazing about
the new world is anybody can do it.
It means it's very competitive.
So, to break out, you
have to bring something.
But you can bring so
many different things.
Let's say, you could be
just a good listener.
Do you know how big of a page you
could build right now on Instagram
if you're just like, hey, my Instagram's
about, like, listening.
Like DME your problems.
I'll just listen.
You'd be fuckin' have 10
million followers tomorrow.
People wanna, you know, people need that.
Yes.
- So, brand doesn't
have an opinion or isn't ready
to actually spend something.
You'd rather advise them to shut up
instead of going like,
hey, it's Father's Day.
Here's a picture--
- You know, it's funny.
I don't, to your point, I think
that's an interesting and smart insight.
I think that if they don't have anything
to say or aren't making great creative,
I think like nine years ago, hey,
it's Mother Day worked on Twitter
'cuz it's a novelty and we thought
it was cool.
I don't think that works as well now,
but let me tell you this.
Boy, would I rather, all the brands
that are running around
here this weekend, pay
an agency eight hundred dollars
for the copy of that tweet versus
the 487 thousand for a commercial
that's bought of remnant
inventory commercial time
that not one fuckin' soul saw.
So, that's the thing, right?
We scrutinize the new
and we accept the old and
they're not even close.
Eight hundred bucks
which would be expensive.
You should pay five bucks,
but agencies, right?
Eight hundred bucks to say happy birthday
or like Father's Day, yay
versus spending five
hundred thousand dollars
with Wieden and Kennedy
and then buying TV time
on CBS, fuck you.
The perfect thing is,
what I think we did with
Stella Artois yesterday,
which has made two minute 13 second video
for Facebook that made fuckers cry.
Everybody here would
wanna make that video.
Because that's what you do
and that's what we do, too.
It's just, we needed two
minutes 13 seconds first
of all to tell the story because
the cut down that they now want,
it's not gonna be good.
First of all, it's not gonna be seen
and second of all, it's
not gonna be as good.
It took us two minutes 13 seconds
to get you to care about the dad
and the girl talking about the dad
for the punch line.
It takes time to set it up.
It's like telling a comedian
that's awesome in stand up to consolidate
it for 30.
You need fucking three.
I gotta get you in.
It's like this talk.
This is a way better talk in an hour
than it is in 30 seconds.
I gotta get you in.
I gotta create the context.
That's what so amazing and
all of you wanna do it.
Because so many people in advertising
wanted to do film and tele, right?
It's a very similar thing.
We now have it, yet we're not doing it.
- How do you at your agency
get across the issues
that we have where we
have these large brands
and all of these regulations as far
as when we're trying to create content,
there is licensing issues--
- Sure, underage, there's
a million different things.
- Yes, a million things.
- We navigate 'em.
Like, we don't break,
if there's a,
if we can't Tweet at,
if we can't use Roger Federer
or Transformers or if we work
Mondelēz's Candy, if we can't market
at 12 years olds and we work on Diageo
and ABI, if we can't market under 21,
those are things we just navigate through.
- Yeah, but I'm in these spaces
where we have 15 to 20 people discussing
a Facebook post and
it's like, oh, one post.
And it's like, oh my God, can we move on
because there is so much more to do.
And it's just these--
- You're preachin'.
- Yeah.
- We don't have that scenario.
We don't have it as much because we think
that would be the biggest
waste of fuckin' time,
especially if it's organic.
You know, like, if you're, you know, like,
to your point, like, and I've seen
in our building, too, like, why did we
have a meeting for 40 minutes on a post
that's gonna go organic that eight people
are gonna see?
Like, you know, if it's
another thing where we're
getting, I mean, we did a Budweiser video
last year where we dropped a container
of beer in the middle of the desert.
I mean, that was a
million dollar production
and we spent a million dollars in media.
That should be debated.
That's money, right?
But to your point, I mean,
even on Twitter now where we think
there's a lot of fertile ground, I'm
going back to the brands right now.
I'm like look, we need to be
in the non-approval game.
Can't be in the approval game.
You can fire us, but like,
to spend any time
debating if we're jumping
into this conversation about Wonder Woman
is not gonna, we should
be held accountable.
We're your partner.
We know your rules and your guardrails.
If we think we're going
close, we may reach
out and be like hey,
this is a little snarky,
but like, spending 45 minutes on a Tweet
that we're hoping catches fire
because we're being culture
relevant, waste of time.
It starts from the top.
I'm the CEO of the company
and I set that tone
for my people and for our clients.
The way I'm talking to
you is the way I talk
to CEOs and CMOs.
Like, fuck you, you're wrong
and they can either work with us or not,
but like, to be half
pregnant is a bad idea.
- [Audience Member] Just kind of going off
of what you were just saying, but
when you were, or I guess, for us
as young creatives--
- Yes.
- Working with older people
in the industry--
- Within your own organization?
- [Audience Member] Yes, who might
be more traditional,
how do you think it's--
- It's tough and you know
what I really really empathize with
for you guys, a lot of your creative,
like most senior creative people, she
and he wants to come in at the last minute
and play that card of ego.
It's just a subjective ego.
They're just rollin' in at 11:59
and be like, not funny, or,
it's just completely subjective.
You've gotta go through, like, I'm pissed
that I have to deal
with the subjectiveness
of the client.
You have go within the subjectiveness
of your own organization
before you even get to the client.
Sucks shit.
(laughing)
I think the way,
yeah, I know the industry.
I think you try to somehow one time
set the tone of a very like,
dear sir, do it however you want,
but whether it's dear sir
or like fuck you, lady.
However you do it, you need to be like,
but don't you think that's just based
on your subjective opinion?
Now, he and she is more than welcome
to say, and that's why I'm
the chief creative officer and that's
what I'm here for.
What, you know,
and listen, that, if you wanna know
why I hate this place,
it's because what I hear a lot of times,
like, I fuckin' wanna can Lion.
I fuckin' think Oscar awards
are subjective bullshit.
What do you think I
think about this stuff.
But that is the industry.
Now, let me tell you why I'm
so passionate for you to go home, start
a private label toothpaste business
that you buy in China, buy
a thousand units, put it on Amazon
and start creating on Instagram
and Facebook and try and figure out
how to sell it.
Then you'll become self contained
and then you can do your own shit.
Because otherwise, there is no answer.
It's based on your culture.
I don't know your company.
At Vayner, our chief creative
officer, Steve Babcock
and the people that work for him know
that if I ever hear a
whisper of them douching
somebody on their opinion,
they're in trouble.
I've learned that every
other organization's
the other way.
But by the way, that
also hurts Vayner, too,
because then what's happened
in our creative place
is that people are
scared to give feedback.
So we went, you know, like,
this is human shit, right?
That's why my model,
what I want for the industry
is the best, because all 13 of you
could have your videos and, like,
could you imagine a creative world
where every idea,
do you know how stupid it is
for you guys to spend
four hours, smart brains,
teams, white boarding shit,
have 13 ideas and then
at some senior person's
subjective opinion to get 'em down
to two to present to a client,
the client, in a one hour period,
who really, she's running a business
of selling biscuits.
She's not a fucking creative.
She picks one of the two
and then all of the money goes
into one 30 second video that goes
on TV that nobody watches.
Yeah, I mean, that examples just not fun.
Versus what I want, which is who came up
with 13 ideas.
You look at all the segmentations,
back to the genders and the incomes.
Like Budweiser means something different
to the 24 year old in Atlanta
that loves fuckin' Gucci, man,
than it does to 63 year old Dick
who loves rifles and fucking fishing
and we can do both now.
Like, a video, like a grampa, white grampa
in Bama with his young
white grandson fishing
and drinking Budweiser targeted properly
on Facebook to 63 year old Bama boy
is gonna work.
In the same way the fucking
Migos pouring Budweiser
and a bunch of dancers in a club
is gonna work on 24 year old Jerome.
Like, I don't understand what people
are doing here.
So, I love the idea of
all 14 of your ideas
for Kit Kat, can see the day of light.
No more debating the bullshit internally.
Cool.
The one thing the senior creative can say,
okay, these six ideas, we're gonna make
into 15 second videos, 19 second videos.
47 second videos for Twitter.
Here, we're gonna do for Facebook.
This one is preroll on YouTube based
on people that buy Skittles that we're
gonna try to convert 'cuz they searched
for Skittles on Google, but we're
gonna run a preroll on YouTube
for Kit Kat being like,
and the video's like you eat Skittles?
Fuck that, Kit Kat.
Like, it's so smart.
It works.
And yet we don't do that.
And so, what's crazy is that I think
a lot of creatives think I'm not
a good guy for creatives 'cuz I come
from a tech world.
They think I'm math.
I come and shit on everything
and they don't like me
and I'm like listen, I'm the one
that fucking gonna open up
the creative world.
I'm the one that's actually gonna make
it good for all of us.
I'm a creative.
Nick came, Nick's here, he's gonna win
a thousand fuckin' awards tomorrow
for his work with Tide.
He's at Vayner now.
Like, he works with me for, like he's
been here three months or something.
Like after the third meeting,
he's like you're a creative.
I'm like, yeah, but that's how I got here.
I know I'm not the creative
that David Droga is
to this industry and I'll say this
to David 'cuz we're friendly.
I'll outsell David every day of the week.
Every day of the week
and I'll make a video
and I'll make creative.
And I'll do a pop, I'll do creative.
But mine's grounded in real life.
Yes, we haven't heard from you yet.
(audience member replies)
Yes, great question.
You know, to me, one of
the things we've done
extremely well in a couple of spots,
so we do plenty of things that make me
want to throw up on myself, but
at our best, the reason
we started a, we have
a 50 thousand square
foot production facility
in Long Island City.
The reason we own our
own production facility
is to drive down the cost of creative.
So, it can run the gamut.
My belief is that copy and very dirty
but nice, I mean, look,
guys, you know this.
You're not dumb.
You don't see your friends
or relatives or people on Fiverr,
like, you may not want to see it exist
because it fucks with our world,
but you can make some badass shit
just on a fuckin' iPhone, let alone,
like, that was another thing.
I was like, how much do
videos cost in advertising?
(laughing)
I'm sure when, I don't
know whenever you decided
to be in this industry but I'm sure
that the first time you heard,
it seemed like a lot of money.
I don't know.
I have a funny feeling,
if I hired all of you for a ninja team
and said, by the way, you have
to make 15 thousand dollar
videos, here's people,
you'd make some killer fuckin' shit.
It's plenty of fuckin' money.
I could do all sorts of damage
for that amount of money,
so we're just driving down cost.
I think at it's best, I think Twitter's
so vibrant now, again, that you could do
a ton of copy, see what pops,
then make the 10 thousand
dollar version, right.
See if it goes and then make
the hundred fifty thousand,
three hundred thousand.
That's the way it should be done.
Not guessing on insight's
work coming into,
like, you know.
That's where I think insight work
and having the ability to hack culture
matter the most.
The two, the answer to your question
ion my brain goes into two places.
True great insight work,
which is not about
interviewing three people
but really looking at big data
and big data's amazing.
I hate that word 'cuz
everybody throws it around,
because it's about analyzing data.
Big data's real.
It's fuckin' special.
It's just an incredible talent
to look at all the cultural signals
and be like, oh shit.
It's about insecurity
amongst 50 year old men
on Thursday.
You know, that takes something, right?
So, big insight work
that gives you pillars
and then what I call culture hacking.
When things are happening in culture, you
make creative quickly and see if that's
a place where your brand can play.
So, I think it's actually,
I think everybody plays
in the middle.
They go into brainstorming
and they're like, okay, we're
gonna stand for optimism or we're gonna
be utility or we're gonna
own St. Patty's Day.
I'm more like, no, you gotta go
way deeper and be like,
this is about mom's being,
let me give you an example
of how I think about insight work.
'Cuz I do a lot of it myself.
A lot of parents right now want
to blame social networks for teen suicide.
Teen suicide, if you do insight work,
has a lot more to do with the fact
that parents are so over
coddling their tit children
in the first eight to
nine years of their lives
'cuz parents are now so
deep in their kids' shit,
they know everything.
They, fuckin' ninth place trophies.
Anybody that gets picked on
is a fuckin' catastrophe and it's gotten
so extreme that by the time a child
is nine, it has never
dealt with any adversity.
By the time they start actually dealing
with adversity, they're like a zoo animal
being put in the wild.
That's insight work.
That wasn't so,
like we didn't know that was happening.
We had to get there.
Like, oh shit.
So, I'll give you another one.
I think non-healthy foods
are about to explode.
Foods with like sugar and like,
because in a world where
like fuckin' parents
are worried about their kids getting shot
in school and heavy political stuff,
all of the sudden, giving little Ricky
a Twix versus some healthy, fuckin' vegan,
tricked out product doesn't seem like
the biggest issue that
it did six years ago.
And so now, I see insights
that show me, hmmm,
this might be the great
year for sugar candy
and cereal to take a position of, hey,
and here would be the pillar.
However you would creatively manifest it.
It would be, hey, mom,
in this world that we now live in,
wouldn't it be nice to just give Ricky
a cupcake.
It's okay for Ricky.
You had a cupcake.
You turned out okay.
Like, a cupcake would be okay.
That's an insight that
can really go somewhere
that you could really win with a mom
that's shopping down
the isle at Albertsons.
So, deep insight work
and then, to that same mom, you know,
Modern Family gets canceled and you got
a funny perspective and you got
a good copy writer bangs in with
some sort of Tweet.
It click and becomes a whole thing.
Scandal starts blowing up and you're
the wine brand that owns
drinking wine during Scandal.
You figured it out 'cuz you're
from Washington state and you fuckin'
took advantage of Kerry Washington
being on the show.
None of the Washington
state wineries did that.
They should have.
And they should have done it through
a lot of copy and that
would have got into that.
See where I'm going?
- Okay, so you, you're
speaking nothing but truth.
- Okay, thank you.
(laughs)
- And you have a lot,
like your strong views
and insights--
- yes.
- And so, where did you learn those
and did any of them come from mistakes
and if so, what were the mistakes?
- The mistakes are the best part.
When you're producing as,
this is DRock.
He's been filming me for three years.
Everyday, we put out a vlog.
We put out tons of content.
The truth is, almost all of it's mistakes.
That's the beauty of,
that's what's so scare,
why do you think nobody wants
to buy into creative for
my Silicon Valley world?
We could do all this right
and you could still spend 300 thousand
on a video even though it would
have cost a million and it would fail.
So, through experience.
You know, what really,
and I mean, this is not thought out.
I got real lucky in my life experiences.
For example,
this is really weird to bring up
the attention thing, back
to getting goosebumps.
I, as a six year old,
had six lemonade stands.
Tricked my friends into standing behind
the lemonade stands and I would walk
the streets of New Jersey looking at cars,
looking at poles and trees.
I actually forgot about this.
During a speech in real time,
'cuz you can see I kind
of improv it, I remembered
that this is what I used to do.
I was, I am such a natural trader
of attention, that intuitively
as a child, I understood that if I put
my lemonade sign on that tree
versus that pole, that that would
have an effect, in hindsight.
I didn't realize what I was doing.
Baseball card shows.
I was a big baseball card dealer
when I was 12, making a lot of money.
They were big.
I'm old at the time.
I used to walk the show for three hours
and set up my table after everybody else
because I would walk it, figure out
the current, as I used
to call it back then.
What was hot?
What was happening?
And then I would go back to my table
and I would, God, it's so funny
to think about these days.
I used to walk it.
I used to walk, like make pretend
like I was a normal person.
Be like, what could I put
on my table that would stop you
and then, the ultimate.
And I would tell you, the great thing.
You're so young, you could still do this.
Literally, work one year at retail
and watch your career change.
Right, I see some of you shake your head.
I used to stand behind the register
at my dad's liquor store
and I would watch people walk the store.
Later, that became why I was so good
at UI and UX on the web,
because I had already,
and these are all things
now I'm telling you.
I didn't understand I was doing them.
Now, I can reconcile it.
That's how I built my dad's store.
It wasn't just marketing.
It was, wait a minute,
if people are all going this way
because that's how we set up the store,
maybe I should put
higher profitable items,
why do we have the jug wine there,
which is shit, why don't I put
the good wine, you know,
and just,
at the register why do we have
these fuckin' minis for alcohol
which you make a penny on.
Let's put like half bottles
of champaign that are like,
and people are picking,
and so, the answer is,
because all I've ever done
is been obsessed about the consumer.
For example, when I put out content now,
I don't watch other peoples' content.
I don't really even think about my own.
I watch how people react to my content.
I read every comment.
I'm a deep practitioner
of consumer behavior in action
and that's what makes,
when you're seeing what I do,
it's so natural.
I pitch my full insight
and creative in rooms.
The whole thing.
To the point where like
when I started hiring grown
up people in agencies,
after they left, they're like,
no no no no, don't do that.
That's what we have to get paid for
to present eight weeks later.
I'm like, oh shit, okay.
(laughing)
You know, 'cuz it comes so,
I'm so in tune.
Because really, you'll
find this interesting.
The word that elevated to me is empathy.
I have empathy.
A lot of it.
That's why I'm a good CEO.
It's why I,
it's what it, I come into this room
only trying to bring you value.
I have empathy.
I know what you're,
and that's serviced me well as leader
and a salesman and a marketer
and I deeply am religious about it.
- Hi, my name is Josh.
- Josh.
- Nice to meet you.
- Pleasure.
- I'm curious.
Are there, who are the people within
either the advertising industry
or any industry as a whole that you look
up to or you learn from?
What are the lessons that you--
- That's a great question.
So, I don't consume a lot.
But I gravitate a lot
more to Vince McMahon
and Walt Disney.
I love people that can create IP at a,
I think Vince McMahon built
an incredible business model around IP.
He gets people into
characters, like Hulk Hogan
and Andre the Giant.
They're based on humans and
unlike being William Morris
or CAA or like a sporting
league, he owns the IP.
It's actually fucking brilliant.
Right like, he creates,
in theory, superheros
out of humans and the human can't take
that IP with them.
It's really smart and then,
how he builds up the story lines
to get you to care.
Very interesting to me.
Same with Disney.
I just think that he
built an entire universe.
So, I like people that create IP.
It's why I, you know, I don't know much
about it, but I know
enough to say it in here.
It's why Leo Burnett in
the '70s, when they were,
in the '60s, when they were creating
the Marlboro Man and Jolly Green Giant
and Keebler elves, I have a lot
of respect for that.
I would say, we just did some work
for Birds Eye or something where we had
an avocado, right, like I don't know
if that hit your guys' radar.
I'm trying to push my agency towards,
what?
(audience member replies)
Royal Bank of Scotland,
you're exactly right.
We have two birds for Birds Eye.
Makes a lot of more sense.
Yeah, I mean, Royal Bank of Scotland
for our London office,
we literally created
an avocado character.
If we hit, it's forever.
And I don't think we're taking those risks
in creative anymore.
We're trying to make that video
that makes you laugh but
we're not building IP.
And when you build IP, it's forever.
The Trix rabbit is still here, right?
MetLife pays Peanuts a
lot of money for Snoopy.
Geico, that shit matters.
So, I'm very in,
that's what I'm inspired by.
That's why I want to buy nostalgic brands.
That's why I was obsessed with Marvel,
the comic book company
when it became a movie.
I mean, it was a bankrupt
comic book company.
Bankrupt comic book company.
Trillion dollar movie company, you know.
Pretty cool.
I tried to buy Animal
Crackers from Mondelēz
a couple years ago.
Prematurely for me, but
it was such a good deal,
because I was gonna make an animated film
and I was gonna make America care
about the elephant.
I was like, if Madagascar
and Ice Age matter, I can
get every grandparent and older parent
to bring their kids to Animal Crackers
'cuz they all grew up with those crackers.
Easiest story line ever.
Crackers turn to life.
Away we go, right?
(laughing)
So, that's what inspires me.
- I'm Gloria.
- Gloria.
- You talked a lot about
doing different content
in terms of Twitter, Facebook video,
things like that.
- Yup.
- How do you feel about
physical installations
and doing--
- Love, love.
Love the physical world.
Obsessed.
As a matter of fact, Vayner Experience,
which is the vision we
have for experiential,
is one of my favorite projects.
My chief hard officer, Claude Silver,
is no question the most
senior executive besides me.
Like, this is real.
We care to know.
Otherwise, we should just fire them.
What are we doing here?
I'm so pumped you asked that
because I'm so in it.
I spend an ungodly amount of time on HR.
(laughing)
I love it.
Most people don't want to,
especially the CEOs,
especially in my status,
want to be in the Karen
is ruining me business,
but I do.
I want to know, because it's how we
can build, I think we can beat
the whole industry by giving a fuck
about people, because they can't.
All the holding companies here can't,
because they're running
financial arbitrage models
and every person is just a line item.
(audience member replies)
A hundred percent
and I'm trying to build forever.
I look at Jason, Nick, Emily and DRock
and like, I only have one KPI.
Can I keep them forever?
And that means a lot of things.
Emily's on her fourth different thing
in our organization.
When Nick came over,
there was a side hustle
that he had that I knew I had
to be very in.
I spoke to Bob Memory for like an hour
the other day to make
sure he over delivers
for Nick's campaign.
Jason's switching now.
He pitched me a music concept.
I listened.
I didn't appease him in that 15 minutes.
We might have started a music thing.
He decided to go be a top production dog
in the publishing arms.
And that's just four of them
and I didn't get to DRock, I like,
am super close to we're always together.
The reason he's the easiest is he knows me
the best of the four of them,
so I'm not, I'll be very honest with you.
I take him for granted the most
because he knows exactly who I am
as a human being and I know anybody
that knows exactly what I'm up to.
I'm safe as fuck.
He may wanna do other things,
but he knows better than anybody, right,
so, and that's four of them
and of the 850, I knowing fucking
a ton of shit about 450 of them
and the other 400 are just not giving me
the chance yet, 'cuz they're still cynical
'cuz they used to work at Crispin.
- Gary.
- Yes.
Like you always, like
your gospel is social.
Is it gonna continue to be that?
- Of course not.
If I entered this universe in 2001,
my gospel would have
been email and search.
- Okay.
- Can't be.
The attention's gonna move.
It's why we've gotten so big into voice.
It's the first place that I see
could be really a powerful land grab.
And social's very kind of broad.
To me, it's what platform lives
on top of the cell phone
is what my gospel actually is.
The cell phone is the remote control.
It is the place
and we've also thrown things
like YouTube and LinkedIn into social.
Right?
The only social network, in my opinion,
is Twitter.
It's a true social, you know,
water cooler.
Instagram and Facebook have
become content platforms
where you push.
Yes, people can comment,
but most brands don't go in there, right?
So, LinkedIn, my God.
I can't believe how serious
we're taking LinkedIn now.
I mean, because nobody else is.
My content is flooding LinkedIn
and a lot of my B2B world
has been build on that
and by the way, this is back to context.
One thing that I told the team,
this is unheard of.
I never filer.
I'm like, hey guys, I think we have
to start beeping my cursing on LinkedIn.
I'm exploding but for so
much of that audience,
the cursing is really turning them off
and I have to respect that.
That you're in a different room
in LinkedIn than you are on SnapChat
and what works for 18 year old Sandra
is not playing for 64
year old Joel as much
and so, I have to be thoughtful of that.
And even if it was Sandra, again,
this is, by the way, this is
the most interesting thing
about these platforms,
same person, different
platform, different person.
- Yup.
- So fascinating for me
to watch that.
What you're looking for, you.
You're in Twitter.
What you're gonna react to
and convert on, one minute later, you go
into YouTube or LinkedIn or Facebook
and I've gotta give you some version
that's slightly different copy-wise.
That's why I love copy.
Copy is the great under
rated thing right now.
You make a great piece of creative.
If you change the copy in
all six platforms, you know,
I want you to edit the video,
but I know how much money
is involved in that,
so just changing the copy on LinkedIn
versus Facebook versus Twitter
versus Instagram gives
you a huge opportunity.
And people spend so much time on the
actual asset, but
underestimate how powerful
that copy that associates
it can be and is.
- [Woman] Last question.
- Who hasn't asked anything?
You, sir.
Smart move.
(audience member replies)
About what, my friend?
Company Morocco specializing
in dairy products.
Keep going.
30% of the company is owned
by a dirty, filthy politician.
For the bad politician
to not do the dumb shit
in the first place.
(laughing)
It's a very important point.
I'm not joking.
That's what I love about the world we
now live in.
You know, look, I mean, I think the move,
and let's say that was
my cousin's business
and 30% of the company was a partner.
I would go on a very
heavy campaign alienating
the former partner and talking about
the product benefits.
But the reality is, is like,
that's the game we live in, right?
You look at all, rightfully so,
these iconic personalities in the U.S.
going down on the #metoo movement.
People reaching out to
me, buying channels,
saying hey, how do I protect against this.
I'm like, you don't.
The truth always wins.
It took a long time,
but Christopher Columbus'
brand got affected,
you know what I mean?
The truth is gonna win.
And so, I think what the brand should do
for the 70% that are probably good people
and like, fuck, they need to alienate,
the, alienate, and they
may not want to do that
because in real life,
they may be best friends.
I don't know the dynamics,
but what would I do in advice?
Alienate
and then go aggressive
on the product values
of why it became the
leader in the category,
but step one is alienate
against that individual,
'cuz you have to stop that bleeding.
- Alright, so we're gonna
take a large selfie,
if it's cool.
- Sure.
- Well, not really a selfie.
A stand back.
So, let's do the same thing we did.
You two aren't in the class.
Can you actually--
- Get the fuck out of here guys.
(laughing)
- Yeah, no offense.
- You guys are not young.
Back there, I need you to leave.
You're old, please get--
(upbeat music)